what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have a lot of DC news
including our first set photos of Lady
Gaga as Harley Quinn or I should say as
harleen quinzel and I do say that for a
very specific reason and we'll talk
about that in just a bit but we also
have the rock breaking his silence on
Henry Cavill no longer being Superman in
the MCU yesterday in an interview with
variety he finally opened up and gave
his thoughts on what all happened and
how he feels about it and of course we
have to talk about that major Shazam
Cameo that was recently spoiled by a TV
spot spoilers incoming for that we won't
mention it now but we will tell you when
we're about to talk about that but first
let's kick it off with the new photos
from the set of Joker 2. now almost a
week ago set photos were revealed of
Joaquin Phoenix he was fully dressed up
as the Joker however in some of these
scenes we also see other Jokers appear
now the internet has gone crazy trying
to figure out what this could mean there
are many theories out there right now
some of them include well this is just a
dream The Joker is dreaming and he has
seen multiple versions of himself in a
dream other theories include well these
are some of his followers they are
simply dressing up as him now and of
course there have been some theories
stating that these are variants of him
but no this is not the Marvel Cinematic
Universe this is not the new DC Universe
this is a DC else worlds project these
are not variants and if they are he is
definitely dreaming them but they do
show us the joker out of Arkham Asylum
if he is not dreaming that is and new
set photos that have come to Service
Today Show us Lady Gaga as Harley Quinn
but like I mentioned in the beginning
it's really harleen quinzel at this
point this is sort of the origin story
for Harley Quinn and it's still kind of
the origin story for the Joker at the
end of the last Joker movie he just
became the Joker but he really hasn't
done anything as the Joker Persona yet
so that's what we're assuming is going
to be explored in Joker too and if you
haven't heard there's a big rumor going
around that they're actually going to
change something with Harley Quinn and
if this rumor is true some people might
be kind of upset with this The Insider
on Twitter Casey Walsh revealed before
deleting his tweet stated that there
could be one key aspect of Harley
Quinn's backstory that could be
massively changed and that is the fact
that she is not going to be a
psychiatrist at Arkham Asylum but in
fact a patient at Arkham Asylum this is
a pretty big change to her origin story
and right away let us know in the
comments if this happens are you okay
with this do you like it do you hate it
let us know now it is worth noting that
he did delete his tweet this could be
because he was asked to delete it by the
studio or it could be an accurate so
treat it as a rumor or now some people
like Twitter user the real Wolf Gang
have pointed out that two crazy people
falling in love is more realistic than a
doctor but it sucks if it's true and
there have been plenty of people already
expressing disappointment in this so
they set photos of Lady Gaga do show us
harleen quinzel it doesn't look like she
is truly Harley Quinn yet what a lot of
people have been guessing is that by the
end of this film she will become the
Harley Quinn much like the first Joker
movie the entire movie led up to him
becoming the Joker at the end so we're
expecting something pretty similar with
this movie and Harley Quinn but as far
as the look goes Lady Gaga does look
like Harley Quinn she doesn't have any
of the tattoos or the hair of the get up
in this photo but we can definitely see
how she would be a great Harley Quinn
once all of that finally happens now
they might save that reveal for the
movie we may never get set photos of it
or a TV spot for it or trailer so we'll
have to wait and see on that but we can
definitely see here that she will look
pretty good as Harley Quinn so let us
know your thoughts about all of this in
the comments down below now moving on to
last night at the Oscars on the red
carpet where variety got to speak with
Dwayne The Rock Johnson and they asked
him how he felt about him bringing back
Henry Cavill as Superman and then Warner
Brothers to deciding that he wasn't back
this is what he had to say in the
interview with variety
Henry Cavill you brought him back but
now they're saying he's not playing
Superman what do you say
um
you know
all that I could do and that we could do
when we're making Black Adam was to put
our best foot forward to around
ourselves with the best people and then
also deliver the best movie we could we
our audience score was in the 90s uh uh
critics you know took a couple of shots
that's just the business of it though
um
but I think it's almost like when you
have a pro football team and your
quarterback wins championships the head
coach wins championships and you have a
new owner and the new owner comes in
says not my coach not my quarterback I'm
gonna go with somebody new so you could
tell here right when he gets asked this
question by his facial expressions that
he is thinking about what to say he
wants to say the right thing and not
something wrong he doesn't want to throw
anybody under the bus that's just not
how Dwayne The Rock Johnson is and he
says it pretty perfectly he tried to
make the best movie that he could and
this movie was in the works for over 10
years and The Rock truly thought that he
was going to be a big part of the DC
Universe moving forward and he wanted to
bring back Superman Henry Cavill
Superman specifically to be a part of
that but then of course James Gunn came
in with a completely different plan it
wasn't personal in any way but he knew
that the DC Universe had to basically be
reset and they had to start from scratch
and that's basically what Dwayne Johnson
is referring to here when he says you
know a new owner comes in and says
that's not the coach that's not the
quarterback and basically that's what
James Gunn did he came in and he said
hey that's great that's a great track
record that you have here it's a great
movie you just did however not my
quarterback not my universe we're
starting over but he did say that he is
still willing to work with seven bucks
production Dwayne Johnson's company and
they're both open to Future
possibilities so hopefully Black Adam
can return hopefully Henry Cavill can
make a cameo somehow the Multiverse is a
thing now in the DC Universe so who
knows but kudos to Dwayne for keeping it
classy and not throwing anybody under
the bus now from here we are going to
dive into some slight spoilers for
Shazam now this spoiler was on a TV spot
that Warner Brothers themselves released
so it's not exactly a spoiler but if you
are trying to go into Shazam 2
completely blind I would click away for
those of you still here they have
revealed that Wonder Woman is going to
make a cameo in Shazam 2 and they showed
her in a TV spot you could check it out
here this was on TV but this is coming
from the Twitter user cryptic HD quality
oh my God stick to saving the world kid
Shazam has been delayed where the
lightning bolt of perfection
it's an electrifying Adventure so that's
right Shazam Fury of the guards 3D PG-13
so yeah a pretty big reveal here now she
most likely isn't going to have a major
role in the movie Just a cameo and
probably just for comedic relief as we
kind of know that Wonder Woman is Billy
Batson's crush and we can even see him
here as Shazam doing a phone signal with
his hands putting it up to his ear and
basically saying hey call me but Wonder
Woman walks away gives us a little grin
and says stick to saving the world kid
so again probably just in here for
comedic relief and just to have a fun
Cameo now something to keep in mind
however is that this is taking place
before the Flash and during the flash
the whole universe is going to reset and
we are basically getting our new DCU yes
James Gunn has stated that some
characters are kind of going to stay the
same but as far as Gaga does Wonder
Woman is concerned he has openly stated
that they're not sure yet but they are
continuously talk talking to gout about
what could possibly happen but it is
interesting that they chose to show
Wonder Woman in this TV spot and footage
leading up to the movie now this movie
has some controversy surrounding it so
this is most likely an attempt to get
people excited to go watch it and the
director of the film David F Sandberg
has shared his thoughts about this TV
spot stating well there's some big
Shazam spoilers out there now if you
want to go in fresh maybe don't be
online or watch TV with ads pretty good
advice in general actually then he
continued to state I'm happy if it
convinces people to see the movie but
it's of course less ideal for people who
are going to see it anyway if they
happen to see spoilers regardless of
them putting it on TV it's still going
to be pretty cool to see Wonder Woman at
least one more time in the DC Universe
it'll be nice if this truly is the end
of Gal Gadot as Wonder Woman but hey let
us know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below are you going to see
Shazam 2 are you excited about it do you
think it'll be good be sure to let us
know and don't forget to like the video
and subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest ECU news of course you
can follow us on Instagram and Twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
foreign